اراد ان يتباهى امام عشيقته واظهار قدراته
ومهاراته في قياده سفينه ضخمه على متنها
الاف الركاب
فتسبب بكارثه راح ضحيتها العشرات
الاسم فرانشيسكو
التهمه القتل غير العمد المكان ايطاليا
الحكم السجن 16 عاما
في الثالث والعشرين من يناير عام 2012
سفينه سياحيه ضخمه تحمل اسماكوستا
كونكوردا وعلى متنها اكثر من 4000 راكب
كانت تبحر قباله سواحل ايطاليا قبطان
السفينه كان الايطالي فرانشيسكوشيتينو
البالغ من العمر 52 عاما وكان يومها برفقه
عشيقته الرومانيه والتي كانت ايضا من ضمن
طاقم الرحله بدات رحله السفينه كاي رحله
عاديه لكن شيتينو اراد التباهي امام
عشيقته وابراز مهاراته في القياده والتحكم
اجرى مناوره خطيره وغير قانونيه في محاوله
منه للدوران حول جزيره صغيره بتلك السفينه
الضخمه غير مبال بسلامه الكم الهائل من
الركاب على متنها اتجه شيكينو بالسفينه
نحو الجزيره لكنه لم ينتبه الى الرادار
الذي حذره من اقتراب الاصطدام بها وهذا ما
وقع فعلا اصطدمت السفينه بصخور الجزيره في
الغرق وفور وقوع الحادث كان اول تصرف من
شتينو انه هرب مع عشيقته دون انذار الركاب
او الطاقم بما حدث تاركا وراءه الالاف
يواجهون مصير الغرق لحسن حظ الركاب وصل
الرجال الانقاذ في الوقت المناسب لكن ورغم
ذلك تسببت الحادثه بمقتل 33 شخصا غرقا
واصابه العشرات بجروح وفي تلك الاثناء كان
شيتين قد وصل الى اليابسه وراح يدلي
بتصريحات كاذبه حول مساهمته في انقاذ
الركاب متوسطه
بعد الحادثه القت السلطات القبض على
شيتينو الذي انكر تسببه في غرق السفينه في
مقاله حبيبته انه بقي داخلها ولم يكن اول
الهاربين
سمعت انهم اتهموا الكابتن بالهروب اولا من
السفينه لكن هذا غير صحيح فالكابتن كان
يعطي اوامر لانقاذ الركاب واعطاني اوامر
بالذهاب الى قريب النجاه
الادعاء الايطالي اتهم شيتينو باجراء
مناوره غير قانونيه للدوران حول جزيره
بالاضافه الى ذلك رفعت عليه قضايا بسبب
طريقه تعامله مع الازمه واتهامه بالهروب
من مكان الحادث قبل اجلاء المسافرين عام
2016 اصدرت محكمه ايطاليه حكما بسجن
شيتينو لمده سته عشر عاما بتهمه التسبب
بالقتل وبوقوع تلك الكارثه البحريه 16
عاما سيقضيها القبطان العاشق في السجن
نتيجه الاستهتار بارواح الناس في سبيل
مجرد التباهي امام عشيقته